what really is a problem and I think
it's a developing problem we're no
longer at the point day where it's
Republican versus Democrat this is now
Washington versus the rest of America
[Music]
this is the Rubin report and I'm still
Dave Rubin reminder everybody to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
click that fancy notification bell
joining me today is the former American
ambassador to Germany as well as the
former acting director of US National
Intelligence Rick Grinnell welcome back
to the Rubin report thanks Dave thanks
for having me good to see you
it's good to see you I appreciate you
doing this my friend this is your first
interview since stepping aside as Acting
Intelligence director so I normally
don't do an interview this way you know
how I like to do it I like to just sit
down and and go but I actually have some
bullet points and I just want to just
plow through a whole bunch of stuff with
you but I think the first most important
thing is you talked a lot about the deep
state Trump talks a lot about the deep
state and yet when a lot of us talk
about the deep state people say oh this
is a conspiracy theory this is made up
it does it's it's not really a thing
there's no way to define it so when I
say deep state to you what does that
actually mean I think to me what it
means is that there's this system in
Washington DC the federal government
system that basically takes care of its
own you have to be living in Washington
DC to work for the federal government
largely I know there are people that
will say well that's not true there's
different you know offices around the
country I certainly wish that there were
more because what what really is a
problem and I think it's a developing
problem we're no longer at the point day
where it's Republican versus Democrat
this is now Washington versus the rest
of America and what I would say that the
deep state is is the system in
Washington that protects its own
everybody who gets a job in the federal
government has to live in that area
largely and that means that they flow
from one agency to another they're
dependent upon the federal government
the media that lives there is dependent
upon Washington DC being large and big
and powerful and when Republicans or
Outsiders like Donald Trump come in and
say you know what let's shrink this
let's cut this let's change this there
is this rise up of people protecting
their city protecting the state that
they have built up and when we have
economic crashes Washington DC has never
hit because the federal government has a
bunch of workers that continue getting
paychecks when we had COBIT and people
were cut why is it that all of the
people that were standing up saying stay
at home don't work put on a face mask
don't go out and participate in the
commerce all of the people warning us in
telling us that were people who had jobs
all of Washington DC kept getting paid
all of Washington DC workers were
staying at home they didn't have a care
in the world because they weren't
working but they were collecting the
same paycheck they are unaffected
largely when there is a crisis and so
it's this system that takes care of its
own let me also just say quickly when a
job is opened up let's say at the
Director of National Intelligence office
the OD and I where I worked we post the
job on these websites that are only
known by Washington DC types or largely
known by Washington DC types they know
the lingo they know how to go to the
office because it's a local office they
have been the deputy assistant secretary
of this and that and then they get to be
the assistant secretary of this and that
and it builds on this oh well you you
have to have the federal government
lingo access and job title in a
consecutive order in order to get the
bigger job so it's a system that takes
care of its own and when an outsider
comes in the retin is the whole system
like Donald Trump
so I actually wanted to get to this a
little later but I think it's the right
segue can you talk about how that
system then is linked to the mainstream
media how every article that comes out
in the New York Times that is supposedly
in a classified meeting suddenly gets to
the New York Times first and then CNN
and the rest of it how they're actually
working in cahoots yeah and look it's
manat that different then say you know
we're in Los Angeles and so the
Hollywood crowd and the Hollywood media
go to the same parties they go to the
same church they live on the same block
they see each other at the post office
so there's this institutional system
right if you're working at say Disney
and suddenly you're switching jobs and
you're working at NBC and you get a
bigger job you're still talking to the
same people in your neighborhood and
you're still talking to the same media
the relationships begin to be incestuous
and you take care of each other because
you're fighting for Los Angeles the same
things happens in Washington so when the
media go to Washington you know the
Jeffersonian principle is that
politicians and people are supposed to
go to Washington on a temporary basis
Washington is supposed to be this
temporary place it's now got sports
teams it's now got huge infrastructure
it's got systems like a city and now
they're saying we should be a state
because we have so many people that's
not the design of Washington DC
Washington DC is supposed to be the
place where you go temporarily to make
laws and then you leave that place and
you go home and live under those laws we
have a system right now where the media
control it because they live there and
they switch from the New York Times to
Politico to the Washington Post to CNN
and and all around they just stay in
that system and they protect their own
and so I think it's a real problem and
by the way term limits is not going to
solve it it's an it's one aspect of it
but if you limit the the politicians
terms to six years or whatever you're
giving more power to the bureaucracy
into the deep state because they're
there and and the person who just cycles
out is the politician that's that's the
name on the door and the power becomes
that those staffers now now one solution
cuz I want to always talk about
solutions yeah is that we need to move
some of this bureaucracy out into the
Midwest into the rest of the country why
is it and I think kovat is the perfect
example to show when there's a problem
when there's a crisis we shouldn't have
everything based in Washington DC that's
not healthy and so is there a way to
start moving parts of the bureaucracy to
Kansas to Missouri to Colorado to some
of the other places where then the
people who are making these decisions
and living in the neighborhoods have
more American values than Washington DC
values how do you think Trump saw this
thing like he this is basically what he
ran on drain the swamp and I don't think
people really knew exactly that meant
the deep state as you're discussing it I
think they meant he they I think most
people thought he man Oh drain the swamp
like I just just sort of career
politicians but not like a structure
just like people who we vote in just the
politician sort of why have you ever
talked him about that like how did this
New York businessman see that thing that
most of us didn't see you know talked to
him a little bit about it one of the
things that's really interesting about
President Trump is he's always been an
outsider even as a billionaire in New
York and a big developer he's always
been an outsider he's always been
somebody who the system has looked at
with was suspect and so he has the
innate quality to kind of take on the
system take the criticism he toughed
through the criticism not let the
criticism affect him and and that's a
powerful combination I also think it's
why there's a lot of gay conservatives
and black conservatives who who are
tough enough because they've grown up
against the system of you know you and I
know this is that the the gay leadership
in Washington DC says that you have to
think like this otherwise you're not gay
enough
our friend Peter teal was called not gay
enough
and so there's this you know ideology
now about being gay what's interesting
about President Trump he recently told
me that when he came to Washington DC
for the inauguration to be sworn in as
the 45th president he had never spent
the night in Washington DC he had been
there there for the day but he had never
spent the night imagine spending the
night in Washington DC for the first
time and you're spending it in the Oval
in the White House that's pretty amazing
wow that is incredible you know I was
gonna do a whole interview with you and
not mention the gay thing but since
since you threw it out there in the last
couple days that now that you know
that's a part of me
the gay thing let's just do it for a
second because in the last couple days
you've posted a couple pictures of you
in the Oval Office and you know I've
talked about you know David and I going
tomorrow logo and meeting Trump and how
he was so happy that a gay couple was
there and couldn't have cared less
people have heard that story and they've
heard you talk about that but you posted
a picture of you met your partner Matt
and and vice-president pence and a lot
of people will say all right fine maybe
Trump doesn't care about the gays but
pence really hates them and you know
that da da da da
and yet you describe him as a friend and
a good man and the rest of it could you
do that in like a minute and then let's
get back into the intelligence stuff
yeah he's Mike Pence is an amazing
person he's a committed Christian he's a
realist he's somebody who's just so nice
and thoughtful we talked about Dietrich
Bonhoeffer a lot is a Christian
philosopher that we really both believe
in and and enjoy I feel like you know I
grew up evangelical Christian as you
know I feel like Mike Pence is like my
uncle my dad might you know many people
in the church he is just a good guy he
doesn't hate anybody
he is so nice and he's just religious
and so we can have some sort of
different religious beliefs or beliefs
on social issues and still be really
good friends and I think that's where we
are I love him he always reaches out to
to Matt and me and he's just an amazing
guy all right now let's
back we'll leave the gay thing did it
was that enough was that enough of the
gay will see Kevin again okay so so when
you left the ambassadorship in Germany
suddenly all these diplomats were you
know publicly saying all these bad
things about you and how you've
abandoned them and bla bla bla and
basically I think why Trump hired you is
you called out everybody on Twitter you
were basically like oh you know that's
not what you said behind closed doors or
you know we actually want you to pay for
things yes that's what we're trying to
do it seems pretty obvious to me that in
your short stint as acting intelligence
secretary director that you you brought
that in can you can you talk about just
bringing that attitude in and like the
type of stuff that you pissed people off
about in the intelligence community
first of all I hope that you know me and
I hope I hope that everybody that knows
me knows that I am actually a very nice
person and cordial and never rude I do
have a did you laid in bed with Emma
when she had only like three days left
of life last time you were at my house
so yeah I can vouch for you look I I I'm
a cancer survivor and I talk about that
a lot because it really has changed me I
think I'm a better person because of
cancer because of this terrible
non-hodgkins lymphoma but I hope that
I'm always bringing humanity and in a
heart to even tough conversations and so
I'm having these tough conversations at
a time when it's really important to be
blunt right to be direct can you hear
that phone do it me them that's alright
that's alright it's the deep state
calling man you're in trouble okay
and so what I believe is that we
shouldn't have these conversations and
behind closed doors
we shouldn't have them in secret when
diplomats were first pushed to their
country from from the United States you
had diplomats that would get on a boat
and take a letter and they would deliver
a letter of what the US policy is to the
the foreign minister of another country
and there would be about three people
that would know what that policy is
we now have changed with technology you
get to do diplomacy through what we call
public diplomacy reaching the public and
garnering the public support there are a
whole bunch of people in this world of
diplomacy who still want that
conversation in the back room of the
foreign ministry where four people get
to decide what to do and the public will
get spoon-fed when they are told that if
they are ready to get spoon-fed and I
don't like that I I'm just a different
person I want access I think you know
when you look at how technology has
changed banking we don't we no longer go
to the bank and have a teller we get to
go to the ATM where I get to transfer
money from my home it's upset a whole
bunch of industries including journalism
and and so I think it's upset diplomacy
and and the last people that are
comfortable with it are the diplomats so
they want me to quietly come to the
foreign ministry and just talk about the
foreign policy that we want to them in
the back room in a quiet way and I was
tweeting and I was talking about how
we're developing policy I think that
that's better I think it's a better
system arguably somebody can come back
and say no it's not a good system I get
a lot of people on Twitter who say
that's unprofessional or you're no
diplomat and I look I can take all that
criticism it's silly criticism I think
that the people want to participate and
I am somebody who largely believes that
the people are smart enough a whole
bunch of people think that people aren't
smart enough and that we need to tell
them what to do and I think that we have
a better policy and a better system when
we can include the public and listen to
the public and respond to what they want
so then speaking about what the people
know and can know and can't know and the
rest of it I've heard you talk about how
how to many things are classified that
then we can't figure out what's going on
how do they decide they Anna how do they
decide what is actually classified what
gets unclassified what who gets masked
and unmasked and the rest of it this
will probably get us to the Flynn stuff
too it's it's such an interesting
question and and again
I don't think I can answer this question
without giving a little bit of context
that the system the intelligence
community system and Adam Schiff and
Senator Mark Warner all came at me and
said this guy doesn't have experience he
is inexperienced and he is he is
somebody that we should reject because
he doesn't have experience now the fact
of the matter is my first intelligence
briefing was in 2001 I understand what
this system is all about I have been a
receiver of of intelligence briefings a
consumer of intelligence I've utilized
it inside the UN Security Council and
utilized it in in Europe to move Germany
towards banning Hezbollah for instance
with Iran sanctions I've used
intelligence so the idea that I don't
have experience with silly i-i've had
intelligence briefings before Adam
Schiff and before a Mark Warner both of
them criticizing me I just have a
different perspective right I come at it
from from a consumer of it not somebody
who wrote the intelligence or the
assessments or than the analyzer of it
so when you look at this from the
outside with fresh eyes you look at
intelligence and you say largely why is
this classified I read this in the paper
or this is shouldn't be classified just
because it protects the reputation of
the CIA or the FBI or the NSA
there are times after certain years when
we know something was was going on like
the the Russian investigation and now we
know that it was a big hoax I think that
it's really important to have the public
see from the beginning what was decided
what intelligence officers and others
believed to be suspect information what
kind of pressure they were getting from
politicians at the time I want to open
this up largely because we made a huge
mistake like with the WMD issue the
Russian folks falls right into that
category intelligence is an estimate I
think there are good people in the Intel
community that are working really hard
we have some bad apples just like we
have bad apples in journalism and in
public the police force we have bad
apples but that doesn't mean that we
condemn everybody in the intelligence
community it means we got to get out the
ones that are trying to be partisan with
it and so I was I was pretty good about
having fresh eyes and and come I was
pretty comfortable I should say about
having fresh eyes on the process and
saying this shouldn't be classified and
I don't know why somebody did so I would
declassify it or I decided that at this
period of time between the election of
Donald Trump in 2016 in November and the
inauguration of Donald Trump this is the
transition period where the Trump team
the national security team and Flynn are
starting to get acclimated to the issues
because they are now anointed by the
American people as the incoming national
security team if you look at some of the
transcripts that I Declassified from
Susan Rice and from Samantha power they
will both tell you in those transcripts
which they were under oath in the House
Committee they said sure we talked to
foreigners when we were transitioning
from Bush to Obama during our transition
we were talking to foreign governments
they said that the difference was that
they had a State Department person you
know in the meeting somehow that that
was gonna make a difference I think what
we saw with the Flynn Trump transition
is that people were interested in
learning issues they were talking like
they were diplomats I think when you see
that transcript of Michael Flynn use use
you think wow he's he's a good diplomat
he's trying to calm the situation down
with the Russians he's not trying to
inflame it he's not trying to say screw
them or screw us he's trying to say you
know let's think strategically about
this and have reciprocity so if we do
something and you can come back and do
it but let's not go crazy here with with
come
at each other's throats all right so
then for people that can't get to in the
weeds on all of this then then what is
the problem with the unmasking and and
really how high up does it go and also
just relative to everything going on in
the world right now do you think it's
worth spending a lot of time trying to
actually figure out what happened when
we're in the midst of well Corona it's
hard to tell what's real anymore but we
are in the midst of variety and
everything else all good questions kind
of difficult questions what I would say
first is that unmasking a name is not in
and of itself a bad thing I do think and
the reason why I released the list of
unmasked errs between an augury between
election day and inauguration day is
that's a higher bar for me to want to
dig down and to know who's talking to
whom when we already know who is coming
in as the national security team you
shouldn't be concerned about that unless
you're looking to play politics and so
the idea that you would unmask before we
know who the the president is before
election day
I didn't release that information
because I see where you could make an
argument of how you need to know what's
going on in order to blunt some sort of
you know actions from a foreign
government
um but it's different Dave when we know
who's incoming and you have the Obama
team in in the way that they were doing
it at very high levels and in the
frequency during the transition they
know who's coming in and yet they can't
help themselves
they're digging deep and then what we
know is that the FBI said very clearly
there's not enough information here
let's drop the case on Flynn in the very
next day there's an oval office meeting
with Comey now this is clear the Obama
administration weaponized the
intelligence agencies to go after their
political enemies I don't care what
anyone tries to spin and say that's
exactly what happened and you look at
the evidence from election day to
inauguration day that is the time period
that they
should have said okay we're out we're
we're in transition out they are now
going to be out and they need to be
passing the torch for the American
people to the next people that were just
elected by the American people instead
they were so shocked that they developed
this Russian narrative and I want to
make one thing clear the Russians
interfered in our election debate
largely on social media and they utilize
propaganda I have written extensively on
this issue about what the Russians have
done in Eastern Europe they constantly
go after countries when there's an
election they use propaganda a tiny
sliver of truth and they blow it out to
make it completely an erroneous story
this is what the Russians do
I am very clear-eyed on it I have
condemned them I have written I some of
them I was one of the first people to
write on what the Russians did against
Voice of America and Radio Free Europe
in Eastern Europe and and so I'm very
clear on how they do this in elections
they did it to us but that's no surprise
they always try to use propaganda in our
elections to sow chaos the difference is
is that the the media developed and
blurred this Russian election debate
propaganda into manipulating the Russian
the the American election
most people will hear that the Russians
are interfere in our election that's a
big jump to say when they clearly use
propaganda largely on social media to to
jump in and inflame our debates so that
we'd fight against each other and so I
think that the media did the Russians of
real service they inflamed the debate
even more and they utilized the the very
small investment that the Russians put
in and and they got a whole bunch of
earned media from our American media
yeah all right so if we were to whittle
this down to its simplest terms the
intelligence community said there's
nothing
then there's this meeting with Comey at
the White House and now we know then
this becomes like a two-year run
basically to try to prove some kind of
collusion so if that is in fact true so
I'm taking your word for that
being true so if that is true then then
in effect you're saying we have to
investigate this all the way and that
that could really take out I mean pretty
much everybody right I mean everybody in
the previous administration what I think
Dave is important and what I learned
through eight years of the UN is that
kind of of this transparency and truth
and reconciliation is really important
when you have a crisis and you have a
problem let's come clean and I and I
fundamentally believe in what I think
that the intelligence community the
current intelligence community not the
former intelligence community that the
New York Times and The Washington Post
constantly quote you'll you'll notice
they always say a former intelligence
official that that's clearly a former
person who was a political appointee
it's also a source on Capitol Hill who
could be a janitor you just don't know
yeah the the current intelligence
community was clamoring for reform which
I delivered it wasn't truly it wasn't
most of these ideas were not my ideas I
just said yes to him because the system
was saying we need to reform and the
current intelligence community believes
her a couple of bad apples that they've
got to get out there and that they were
manipulated and I will say this there
were red flags early on in the Russian
investigation from a variety of agencies
and some people made those red flags and
those those comments from people coming
forward and saying this Russian stuff is
not true they classified that
information and pushed it away I've seen
that information and I've called for it
to be declassified it's a process that's
ongoing it takes time I wasn't there
long enough to do it
but there are instances where red flags
were raised very early on in certain
agencies and I've requested that
information to come out and I hope that
it will
all right so just two more quick for you
because I know you're tight on time so I
think the first one is sort of simple
which is why not stay there did
President Trump now I want you to stay
or did you not want to stay I mean it
seems like you're clearly the guy for
the job but it was only you know it's a
couple months really so you know I've
been in Germany for for two years and
and I really decided when we went there
that we weren't just gonna have parties
at night and I wasn't gonna do a
travelogue of how great Germany was but
I was the US ambassador and I was gonna
work really hard to push on US policy
and we did we worked really hard and I
had an amazing embassy Foreign Service
officers who are truly great people who
want to do good work and they were
hungry to do good work and it's
exhausting and and look I I'm totally
healthy I feel great
but I'm also very sensitive about you
know not taking it too far
I had a cancer scare and it was a pretty
serious one that came up fast I'm still
getting checked every three months like
I you know honestly I think that has a
little bit to do with it I was tired I
had in my mind thought that we'd only do
about two and a half years and then when
the president called and asked me to
temporarily do DNI I said 90 days I
think turned out to be more than 90 days
because of kovat but I'm just somebody
that when I have the job I don't want to
sit there and just collect the paycheck
I'm gonna do it to the best of my
ability and when I got in I decided to
go and and reform it because people were
clamoring for it and a lot of
politicians on Capitol Hill got angry
because they wanted me to just sit there
you're the acting you're not supposed to
do anything and I I said you know only
in Washington DC are you supposed to
take a job and just sit there and not do
anything in the rest of the world when
you take a job you actually do the job
yeah I saw you at a couple tweets about
that people were angry that you were
doing the job which is sort of DC 101
okay so just one more for you that sort
of is about everything going on right
now as we watch the protests and the
riots and everything else I think a lot
of people are wondering something like
that this doesn't feel organic
an tyfa actually classify them a
terrorist organization or that's in
motion or i think it's over it happened
when i was on my way out so i think what
has happened is is that the Attorney
General has classified them and they're
now making the the appropriate steps
which means you can go after their
finances you can freeze their finances
and everybody involved
so with that you know so let's just put
people on warning here the accountants
for these people the banks that fund the
money the the workers that work in these
businesses if the person is a CEO or
affiliated or an owner of some sort so
there's a whole bunch and I think the
family members if you've got joint bank
accounts are also going to be affected
yeah you probably saw this but and II
know is now suing Rose City anti-shah
and I have a feeling once they get into
Discovery it's gonna take out blue
cheque journalists and New York Times
people and progressive nonprofits and
the whole thing but my specific question
on that is it feels like as we watch the
riots everywhere and you know
unfortunately well you know I'm here in
LA in New York City like most of the
progressive cities are the ones that are
that are burning do you guys have any
evidence of how much of this was
actually coordinated beforehand and did
you sense that this was coming at some
point because if not that does seem like
some sort of intelligence failure right
cuz this this thing I'm still on going
what I can say is as I know that they're
looking into it I was on my way out by
the time that this was developing and so
I know that there are teams of people
looking at it we've got an amazing
counterterrorism center we've got
counterintelligence people who are
experts and looking into these issues
I know specifically through the
intelligence community and people who
work at OD and I that they are
completely focused on this and there's
one thing that I can say is is that bill
Barr is a great American who wants to be
thorough he wants to be fair he looks at
the details and we're really lucky to
have him all right I know I gotta let
you go but I am doing
one bonus question which is now that
you're back in California I know you
want to relax a little bit you guys are
gonna take some time but this is my
public plea which will be put on YouTube
and Twitter and everywhere else for Rick
Rennell for governor of California will
you make that commitment or mayor of Los
Angeles give me something man we meet
you come on okay so so what I will say
this is that my immediate plans are to
have a gin and tonic at four o'clock and
that's really how far I'm focused on my
life so you're gonna be far more
productive than Gavin Newsom I think
that's what you're saying
all right well it's great when he
desperately needs a new direction my
fear is that everybody is angry right
now at Gavin Newsom for locking us down
and I mean shutting beaches down when
clearly science evidence shows you
should probably be on a beach where it's
hot where you can spread out the
overreaction from the control freaks in
Sacramento was frightening
I know countless people who voted for
Gavin Newsom who say never again what
was I thinking
and so I think he's ripe to be defeated
the problem is is that it's years away
and so that intensity is gonna you know
calm down if he was up in November it
would be a different story but he's
gonna have to work hard to come back and
you know he's also been the leading
assault on our Second Amendment rights
and and he's got some crazy ideas when
it comes to you know trying to take
ammunition and we basically chased out
Olympians who were shooters who couldn't
even practice in California any longer
because they couldn't get their ammo
that's how radical he was when it came
to our Second Amendment rights so
there's a whole bunch of issues that I
think that you could take on Gavin
Newsom on and somebody's going - all
right Rick enjoy the gin and tonic enjoy
a little rest and I'm going to keep the
pressure
on you because I don't think it's not in
your future I'll leave it at that and
everyone can follow you on on Twitter if
you want to see Rick smack down some
foreign diplomats and lay out the truth
it's at Richard Grinnell if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell